[Musik]
doch in unterhosen
hier zu arbeiten was machst du ich mache
heute mädels träumst du das noch aus was
hat der cdu-mann corona bisher besser
gefallen die grenzschließungen oder die
re tradition ali sierung der frau die
die tradition ali sierung der frau das
ist schon ein großes problem aber wir
haben ja nicht nur dieses problem die
haben wir noch ein anderes problem den
50er jahren als war das hatten mit der
drk werbung da gab es wenigstens noch
ein wirtschaftswunder aber das bleibt
ihr ausgeschaut
mit diesem jahr eine frau hat zwei
lebensfragen was soll ich anziehen und
was soll ich komme ja meine mutter hat
immer gesagt kinder und karriere unter
einen hut sie aber unter einem sombrero
ich verbringe meine abende nicht in
irgendwelchen bars oder bei
irgendwelchen sekunden ja wie das so ist
im politischen berlin wo man sich dann
abends trifft und immer wieder die
gleichen leute sieht und die gleichen
themen hat also ich versuche es schon
auch effektiv zu organisieren ja ich
denke ob man sich jetzt irgendwo in
mitte in der bar von ihren sparen zu
klären lässt oder von einem baby dann
dass es eigentlich egal
der unterschied wenn sie sich von dem
baby zu klären lassen dann schaffen sie
damit trotzdem etwas für die ewigkeit ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wären sie lieber allein erziehend oder
die mutter von markus söders kindern
eindeutig alleinerziehend also ich finde
es ja schon sehr fortschrittlich dass
sie ihren parteivorsitzenden robert
habeck einzig auf sein äußeres
reduzieren das finde ich ist ein guter
schritt aber wo gehen die grünen noch
einen schritt weiter ich würde sagen in
unseren klaren forderungen rotor allen
dass wir über gleichberechtigung nicht
nur reden also das wirklich meine
hoffnung eine feministische hop lockt
dann sieht es als dieter corona in dem
bereich jetzt auch er gelernt und damit
eben das nicht mehr so ein schweres
päckchen ist was er einzeln getragen
werden muss haase und zu schweres
päckchen können ja frauen auch gar nicht
tragen sie sind ja schon körperlich
schwächer als männer hammer bizeps
vergleich machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo bin wieder da und haben einen
guten kumpel günter grass hallo herr
oettinger seit corona günther die
meisten güter also hab ich jedoch
erzählt ich okay ich bin die helfer ist
eine chaotische die fragen dafür ist
englisch ja kann man sagen dass die
gesellschaft gerade so mit frauen umgeht
wie du mit der englischen sprache
nein ich glaube so lieblos gegen die
licht mit frauen übrigens ich habe den
beiden würden damals da war meine partei
noch lange nicht so weit das thema
ganztagesschule vorangebracht so weit
bin ich schon ein dass ich für eine
relativ moderne gesellschaftspolitik
ihrer cdu stand du hast also privat und
auch beruflich an der neutralen blick
auf feminismus glaube ja glaube also
lange jahre allein gewohnt während des
studiums vater meine mutter
verantwortlich kleine studien wohnung
aber selbst eingekauft die wäsche
gemacht
ich kann die waschmaschine bedienen also
ohne weiteres nicht was fährst du
eigentlich in städten
ich fahre einen mercedes ich bin schwabe
und eigentlich der marke treu geblieben
ja da wird darüber was schönes reden
hier und nicht nur also ich finde das
alte weiße männer unterm strich mehr für
den feminismus getan haben als so manche
frau die frauen haben ja auch gar nicht
die macht dazu ja ich meine manchmal
hilft halt ein abschreckendes beispiel
mehr als ein vorbild
ich finde es nach 16 jahren einer frau
als kanzlerin ein paar jahren mendes amt
wahrnehmen soll
was für ein herrlich launiger nachmittag
so so plauderten günther dich noch ein
wenig über dies und das bedeutet zu
guter letzt aber auch noch mal ein
zeichen auch die frauen
[Musik]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
eine last
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da